what would you assign to a young phenom
a rapist with mathematics abortion yes
okay so then what would you guys okay so
first of all I appreciate you've created
the static possible scenario for me she
also detected really go whole hog if you
have tense as well so it's vocal
training imaginary victim but you know
the answer is that that doesn't actually
change the calculus meaning that
obviously what happened this person was
an awful awful horrible thing and as I
said earlier the person who raped her
should be tracked down captured killed
castrated so that's number one
[Applause]
the pharmacy mortality divorce and
normally enforcement has not changed
it's on me right the fact that she's
poor and needs an abortion of the change
whether she's rich I needs an abortion
or poor because the abortion argument
we've done do you think this is a lie
for life if you don't think it's like if
you do whatever you want with it if you
think its life you can't do anything as
far as what she does it may be that the
sperm you know that's obviously going to
be an obvious economic person I would
think a lot of people out there like me
William purity
and how about somebody who's obviously
in that sort of situation and there are
charities that exist for people like it
to try and help out and if you know okay
the idea that what about the health of
mothers to my view on a horse again
morality is telling the baby is not
changed as long as the baby now she's
threatening the life's mother and the
decent work maybe threatens legs of
others like for example you have a case
where a woman added actual breast cancer
in community mode era P and she's
pregnant prepared chemotherapy will
abort the baby which actually does
happen right that that is a phase where
mothers should I think be able to get
the treatment that's not the same thing
as an abortion so that she's treating
the mother or what she's got and
byproducts damage today being determined
the baby feel expensive as you think
it's important to note two things one
the solution to something horrible
happen is not another horrible thing
happening in the killing of the baby
except the decadent and who really would
take the marginal case and then use that
to our draw so what people tend to do is
this you know what about the salt is
raised what about her unfortunate so now
let me ask you if you grow longer
you just got pregnant would you think
that you should show that an abortion
right so you're giving me an altitude
getting the exceptional day in order to
prove a rule that you don't have anyone
in defense so you just come up in
absolute so I think the woman should
have an abortion then you can actually
have an argument about or discussion
about in what cases an abortion was
appropriate but you always when people
aren't the pro-choice side the anti-life
sides actually do what they actually do
is they take the marginal they take the
rape you know woman who has a severe
disability and they say this is all
abortion that's not all admitting less
than 1% of all abortions are performed
on women who have been raped because we
want to talk about the epidemic of
abortion country over a million
abortions performed the year in the
United States let's talk about the other
99% of cases when you are willing to
agree with me that the other 99% of
cases are not cases where abortion
should be necessary and I'm going to
have discussion with you about
compliment
I don't do that's what you want I think
you're just using the exceptional case
in order to try it you'll be supporting
a broad base of workers
[Applause]
[Music]
this user to depredation sympathy for
the woman and sympathy for have killed
two people to child okay
[Applause]
[Music]
sodomizing I'm the only one in the
conversations he's expressed his
willingness to take money out of my
pocket and put it in somebody else
[Music]
[Applause]
three hundred thousand other one chosen
here no I don't own a viewing its babies
[Applause]